a few years back I was watching some of
my old childhood VHS tapes and I learned
a lot about myself that day
I watched toddler gessie and I could see
why she struggled with self-doubt as a
teenager and later on into early
adulthood
my dad was not really a part of my life
until I was seven years old
before I was even two years old my
uncles would push me with her feet Place
Birds on my head
asked me if I was pretty or ugly and
proceed to call me ugly if I smiled and
thought of myself as pretty and shame me
for not pulling down my dress when
sitting because I was showing too much
leg
I was a very well-behaved toddler and
followed instructions and I was well on
my way to becoming a professional people
pleaser
something that would cause me a great
deal of pain later in life
my family did what they thought was best
but things didn't get much better once
my dad was in the picture
for me self-doubt became a huge struggle
but looking back it stemmed from shame
and perfectionism
shame because I felt that if I didn't
behave a specific way dress in a
specific way act or speak a certain way
I wouldn't be loved
because my entire childhood was like
that
and perfectionism because it felt like
no matter how hard I tried to please it
was never enough I was never enough
countless nights I waited for my
siblings who shared a room with me to
fall asleep so that I could Crouch down
in the corner of the room and cry
wondering why I was even alive
and praying that God would just take me
looking back self-doubt has stopped me
from trying and striving for many
opportunities and desires
and for so long
I viewed self-doubt as the Ultimate
Enemy
a perfectionist Nightmare and nemesis
but as an adult who's now forced herself
to overcome diagnose social anxiety and
who's pushed herself outside her comfort
zone time and time again I now view
self-doubt differently
I used to think I would finally be happy
if and when I could eliminate all trace
of self-doubt then I could finally be
confident and secure right
or so I thought
I've now realized that self-doubt it
will never go away
but I don't want it to anymore
you see when I finally realized that I
was not put on this Earth to please
everyone around me but to instead be the
best that I could be whether the people
I love like it or not
suddenly I had peace Within Myself and
my actions
I began to accept myself flaws and all
I began to praise myself for improvement
rather than focusing on perfection
and suddenly Perfection was no longer
the goal Improvement was
and this I could be happy with
I still have doubts
I sometimes wonder if I'm a good enough
parent wife friend
or if I'll ever learn the skills that I
hope to obtain or achieve the dreams I
have
but the difference is that these doubts
no longer paralyze me they're simply
thoughts not reality
and I get to choose what I do with those
thoughts
I choose to let them go
failure is no longer something that I
fear
I recently received a graduation
announcement that had a note saying be
allergic to failure and addicted to
success
I immediately wrote back letting this
teenager know don't run from failure
don't fear failure seek it Chase it if
you must failing means you tried it
means you learned you grew
you can't overcome if you don't fall
sure no one wants to fail and make
mistakes but it's now not something that
stops me
one of my absolute favorite memories was
joining a talent show because I love to
sing I'm a horrible singer by the way
but that memory puts a huge smile on my
face even though people actually said
boo
this memory makes me tremendously happy
because I did it I sang in front of over
300 people because I wanted to despite
the fear
despite the doubt despite what other
people thought about me
so if you struggle with self-doubt
whatever the reason might be
know that you are enough you don't have
to be perfect you don't have to have all
the answers and have life figured out
you just need to improve the reality is
that self-doubt is not something you can
eliminate it will always linger but
hopefully silently in the background
little by little one step at a time
congratulate yourself along the way
congratulate yourself for improvement
become your own cheerleader and before
you know it self-doubt will no longer be
your identity
but just an intermittent passenger along
for the right of your life
it's no longer the driver
it's no longer in the driver's seat you
are in the driver's seat
and you get to choose the destination
so make it worth it